[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
westbrook
westbrook for three
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
three
[Applause]
fires away
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
buzzer
steps back for three
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
ariza for three trevor ariza from
downtown
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
wide open for three bang westbrook
westbrook for three bang
mountain puts it up bang bangs it in
kendrick let it go durant does
three-pointer
bang
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
so
[Music]
so
[Music]
me
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
yes
[Music]
is
[Applause]
[Music]
oh
[Music]
oh
get ready
[Music]
[Applause]
let's go home
[Music]
you don't like nba basketball
[Music]
you're telling oh
[Music]
[Applause]
hey
[Music]
upstairs
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
is
[Music]
[Music]
that'll do it the perfect playoff run
complete
the seattle storm of the wnba
champs in 2010
final seconds off the clock and indiana
has won the wnba championship for the
very first time
the clock
[Music]
[Music]
champion
for the third time in five years the
minnesota league
our wnba champion
and they can finally celebrate on their
home floors
they are your 2016 wnba
champions
[Music]
three seconds
[Applause]
redemption
[Music]
guess who is there the seattle storm
have climbed back to the mountaintop
they are your 2018
wnba champion
[Music]
the wait is over for the very first time
the washington mystics
[Music]
so
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
who knows
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
i was born
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
for human life
[Applause]
[Music]
oh that's right lift that bag of
potatoes if you got two inside
[Music]
somebody spilled something on the floor
[Music]
all they ask you to do courtside is hold
on to your drink and don't spill on the
floor
wow beard is every place
some of milwaukee's the miller highlight
spilled on the floor
let's spill some more beer that'll get
the ground going
after this shot won't go
adams grant roberto
[Applause]
[Music]
a big ticket
is this the dagger
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Applause]
yo
game series
toronto has won
[Music]
tonight tonight
[Music]
october 1st
on this beautiful
[Music]
what do we have
[Music]
what is today
[Music]
where
[Music]
[Music]
nobody
[Music]
you know what it is
[Music]
he's not gonna do it
[Music]
we got two people here
[Music]
please
[Music]
me
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
huh
[Music]
um
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
um
[Music]
[Music]
you guys have heard of bct
barbecue chicken theory opponent's
barbecue chicken
take your point you bite it you lick
your fingers
you don't know what that means
[Music]
chicken on them
[Music]
barbecue
[Music]
they call me these
[Music]
the big shamrock
i am
[Music]
i'm out l.a whack get out
three times
he did it again
[Music]
a lot
[Applause]
[Music]
to be honest that ball don't lie it just
came to my head in the game
you know you know how my temper was
guy went to the line you know it was
nothing personal against him
that bought him live
and it just came out
it's a true phrase you know when the
player feels though that the ref might
have called a bad call on him
you heard it on every level now
that ball don't
[Music]
and it was a home game
that ball don't lie i was guarding
louise scholar and you know scholar made
a move
and i fouled him you know but he kept
going
so i found him again
[Music]
you know they called the tech on me
stole the one to the line
shot it shot it
shot it that ball don't lie
hold on
but and it you know it's been living
ever since
and just cannot seem to get
get the proper respect and just cannot
not
sing to get get the proper respect
rookies
[Music]
[Music]
they shot 18 times into the paint they
shot in 18
times and the paint explained it had 32
free throws kawhi shot more free throws
in our whole team
[Music]
we don't get the respect that these guys
deserve
we don't get the respect that these guys
deserve because mike conley doesn't go
crazy he has class and he just plays the
game
but i'm not gonna let them treat us that
way rookie
[Music]
a chance not even give us a chance they
did not
even give us a chance
take that for that i just cannot see
i'm not a number to get the proper
respect
and just cannot sing
[Music]
that these guys deserve because mike
conley doesn't go crazy
he has class and he just plays the game
but i'm not going to let them treat us
that way rookie
[Music]
[Music]
they did not even give us a chance
take that for data
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
sugar rush
[Music]
i want some steak that wasn't filet
mignon
[Music]
bacon lemon bars
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
lemon bars
[Music]
i want some steak bacon donut sugar rush
bacon
bacon doughnut apple fritter
[Music]
[Laughter]
[Music]
jalapenos
we've had a lot of great memories in
this building
it's iconic in the sense of our entire
history of this organization and how we
got to this point
hopefully every fan that was in this
building appreciates the journey and the
ride
every fan that was watching how oakland
held us down
for 47 years
[Music]
foreign
three seconds
[Music]
[Music]
ah
[Music]
the warriors are back
[Music]
warriors
[Music]
he's got it his three
[Music]
that's okay
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
okay
[Music]
all season
[Music]
simmons the screwball
[Music]
simmons
simmons attempting the three-pointer
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
is
[Music]
[Music]
is
[Music]
ladies
[Music]
[Music]
[Laughter]
[Music]
the lakers repeat back-to-back titles
the la lakers the 2010 nba champions
[Music]
and a celebration will begin the dallas
mavericks are
nba champions the first title
in franchise
[Music]
nba champions lebron james captures that
elusive title he's so desperately
coveted
[Applause]
[Music]
what a finish it's back-to-back titles
for the heat
the 2013 nba championship resides once
again in miami
[Music]
[Laughter]
[Music]
and the final seconds set to tick off
san antonio is back on top once again
the spurs of the 2014
nba champions
[Music]
and the dream season is now complete the
golden state warriors of the 2015
nba champions their first title
in 40 years and how sweet it must be
for those crazy loyal bay area fans
[Music]
it's over it's over cleveland is a city
of champions once again the cavaliers
are
nba champions
[Music]
cleveland's long sports nightmare has
ended
the drought is over 52 years
time to celebrate the titles
[Music]
one of the great playoff runs of all
time is complete
[Music]
final seconds here of this 2018 nba
season
there's the buzzer there's a new dynasty
in the nba
the golden state warriors champions once
again back-to-back titles
three in four years and the latest with
a sweep
leonard makes it official now the
warriors just inbound and that's it
there's a new nba champion and it's a
team from toronto canada we the north
are now we the champions the raptors
the 2019 nba champs
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
smoothie on the side strawberry banana
[Music]
chef bread b-roll
man apparently it's a
good meal for me so i can have a good
day at breakfast
[Music]
[Music]
now josh likes to switch it up a little
bit you know
try to keep some southern delicacies
i know he's a georgia boy got to keep
him happy
some apple butter around some biscuits
good bacon man likes to eat
[Music]
got a good palate
knows good food
[Music]
yeah josh got everybody eating trout
sandwiches so
anything else
if you're trying to do something
meaningful
if you don't have the mindset that
you're the best ever
you failed already
so if you don't have the mindset that
you are the best
ever then you already failed
and that's been my mindset since i can
remember
that will be my mindset
as long as i can remember anything
[Music]
that i am the best ever at what i do
and every day every day i will strive to
be that
but my mindset will always be as such as
i am the best
to do what i do
[Music]
and that'll give me a shot at being
but before you can ever reach anything
you have to believe it
you don't just mistakenly become great
at something
you probably have one point at one time
or another believe that you can be great
at that
[Music]
and then you work to get great at that
and you reach that greatness
[Music]
but you don't mistakenly become great
and then you start to believe oh man i'm
great at that no you you believe that
before and you work to get that
so i always believe that and i'll work
every day
and i'll work every day
[Music]
and i'll work every day
[Music]
so high right now
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Applause]
is
[Music]
this is for you
[Music]
this is for you
[Music]
i have one thing to say those
non-believers don't
ever underestimate the heart of a
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
champion
[Music]
[Applause]
oh hold up this guy was doing stuff
these kids still can't do to this day
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
oh
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Applause]
oh
[Music]
[Applause]
oh
[Music]
first
let's go home let's go home ladies and
gentlemen
let's go home
let's go
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
it's over ladies and gentlemen
[Music]
just exploded
[Music]
this is gonna go out on the floor
[Music]
[Music]
so
my mother
[Music]
she's my hero
[Music]
my heart
[Music]
my background
[Music]
the reason why i play the way that i
[Music]
play
it was always there for us
keep me going every day
i'm happy she's my mom
mom you are our spiritual guidance
i wouldn't have it no other way
[Music]
i don't know how you did it
you made us believe
my true hero
[Music]
sacrifice for us
you're the real mvp
and finally for you what would it be
like to one day be a wnba player
i think you mean everything one of the
greatest female basketball players has
probably come up
she smiled all the time but when it was
game time she was ready to kill
i mean who has a turnaround fade away
jumper at 11.
[Music]
i love watching how hard she worked and
how much her teammates loved her
but also her own desire to be great
gigi in many ways represents the future
of women's basketball
a future where a young woman aspires to
play in the wnba
it's like yesterday i was their age i
was a kid i just had dreams and
you know what aspirations she had the
will and determination to be able to
play wherever she wanted
her skill would command respect in the
end
she was a son just starting to rise and
god didn't
[Music]
we promise to carry gigi's legacy
in the 2020 wnba draft the wnba selects
gianna
gigi bryant guard from newport beach
[Music]
so
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
this is
[Music]
to the right
[Music]
[Music]
one last time
[Music]
[Music]
37
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
what three finale for kobe bryant
[Music]
spencer
farewell
[Music]
1433
unbelievable stuff tonight
[Music]
58 points
the lakers
[Music]
farewell performances in any sport
at any time
[Music]
you know it's uh i can't believe how
fast 20 years went by this is crazy
we've been through our ups and been
through our downs
i think the most important part is that
we all stay together throughout
you guys will always be in my heart
from the bottom of my heart i love you
guys
i love you guys and
my family
to my family my wife vanessa i know
there's nathalie and gianna
you know thank you guys for all your
sacrifice
vanessa you holding down the family the
way that you have
there's no way that i can thank you
enough for that so from the bottom of my
heart thank you
[Music]
[Applause]
what can i say mamba out
[Music]
[Applause]
you